what is going on everybody welcome to
the third super computer tutorial series
with our raspberry PI's I am assuming
everyone is using raspberry PI's so
that's what we're going to be talking
about what we need to do now is if
you've got your two raspberry PI's and
you've got your two SD cards what we
need to do is put an operating system on
that are those SD cards and really we
just have to do one of the SD cards
we're going to put the operating system
only on one of them so the first thing
we want to do is we want to get the
image from Raspberry Pi org slash
downloads so we'll go there Raspberry Pi
org slash downloads and on this page
we're just going to download noobs
version or at least for me it's one
three four um I'm not really sure what
the difference between light and unlight
is I'm guessing noobs light only works
if you have the internet or something to
install it anyway I know this one works
that's the one I'm going to suggest you
download so click on that one hopefully
downloads 1.3 gigabytes
depending on your internet how long it's
going to take for you to download it so
if you have really bad internet the wait
a while and so I've already actually
downloaded it so I'm going to go ahead
and cancel this download and I'm going
to continue the video so if you're
downloading it I suggest you just pause
the video and come back whenever you're
done downloading it so once you've got
that installed the next thing you're
going to want is this formatting tool so
click on that and you'll go here and
just download the version that is you
know matches whatever you are so once
you have that downloaded the next thing
you want to do is open up the formatter
so now if you don't have an SD card in
your SD reader I guess I should have
said that you better get an SD reader
but I just assumed everybody maybe has
one I actually have to use one of my old
tops because my current computer doesn't
even have one but anyway so you'll need
an SD reader so the next thing you want
to do is once you've done that the only
thing you have to do is hit option here
and you want to change format size
adjustment to on hit OK and then you'll
hit format so hit OK okay
and it formats it pretty quick and so
now that the memory card is completely
formatted fantastic
so once you've downloaded it you'll
obviously extract it and then go into it
and you'll have all of this basically
there so what you want to do is all you
have to really do is I don't know why
that's like that why all you have to do
is just you know take this and move it
into your SD card slot so I'm gonna go
ahead and do that now copy it into this
G and do some more waiting while this
takes place alright mine is almost done
as you'll find this type process there
is a lot of waiting to be done
so anyways be prepared this was short
compared to one of the weights you'll
have to do now that that's complete you
can eject that SD card and you're going
to want to put it into your pie now for
this next part and really just this next
part I'm gonna have to use like a
standalone camera or something I can use
a screen recorder so you'll have to bear
with me it won't be the sexiest but
luckily it's only for a few seconds that
you'll have to bear with the standalone
camera so anyways let's transfer over
that all right so now once you've got
your SD card with everything you wrote
to your SD card the next thing you're
why I do a fix-it camera a little bit
next thing you're going to want to do is
you can plug the SD card in real quick I
would just say that I like to mark
everything on here so like the SD card
has a 1 on it and that one corresponds
to the node right so the plug also has a
1 on it which corresponds to the one on
the switch which corresponds there's
also a 1 in the
power and where it's plugged in it also
has a one on it so you know exactly what
you've got or where everything is it's
mostly useful in case of like failure
and stuff for you to trace where
everything is but also if you wanted to
turn something off you want to make sure
you're turning off the right thing and
all that so anyway it's just a helpful
tip so the next thing I want to do is go
ahead and plug in the SD card easy
enough just slip it in there and once
you've done that now you want to go
ahead before you turn it on plug in all
the peripherals sometimes when you're
plugging in various USB based stuff it
does suck some power when you do that
and so you run the risk especially if
you're not pushing like what I'm pushing
is if you know fifteen hundred milliamps
if you're only doing like 700 to 800
milliamps and you plug something in you
might drop power for a second now that
might not you know might just be for a
second but you're still going to boot
off and you run the risk of corrupting
the SD card there's a really high
possibility of doing that's like 30%
chance of corrupting it when that
happens so anyway so we'll plug all
those in this is my or my HDMI cord I'll
plug that in and finally I've got this
nice old keyboard any USB keyboard will
do can't have that old circular stuff so
plug that in and now I'm ready to go
ahead and boot this thing up boot up is
pretty simple you just either plug it in
or unplug it and replug it in and
that'll give it the signal to boot up if
your PI does not boot up immediately you
should see here how long it kind of
takes for lights to start blinking
already the monitor is on but if the
eight sometimes like if the AC T which
is this top green light sometimes it'll
blink
really weak and it just never turns on
or gets fully illuminated if you have
something like that happening to you
chances are you have a corrupt SD card
and in fact I'm gonna have to go ahead
and unplug it chances are you have a
corrupt SD card or your power supply is
too weak or your pi is bad but the
highest highest likely possibility there
is
that your your your power supply was
probably pretty weak or your SD cards
corrupt it's unlikely that your pie is
the problem okay so once you have all
that ready you should be able to see the
installation for the operating systems
on your screen so I'm going to move the
camera up now and so here you have your
option sorry again for the poor screen
recording this is the best it's going to
get for now though and after this I
think this will be the last step so
anyway you can use the arrows on your
keyboard and go through all these if you
want to look at what you can install
basically you can that's why like noobs
as you can install kinds of different
operating systems and just kind of play
around and see what you like but for us
we're going to use raspbian so kind of
highlight that hit enter and then to
install you can just hit the I key on
your keyboard and it yes good stuff okay
and then this process will go on and on
and on and so it'll probably take a
little bit so I'm going to go ahead and
stop the video here we'll continue on in
another video with the next steps and
we'll actually be on a screen recorder
from there I'm pretty sure so no more of
this silly screen stuff so anyways
hopefully you guys are having fun if you
want to play with your new Raspberry Pi
after this installs what you can do is
as soon as it boots up type in a start X
and that will get you started I don't
even know if the first time you login
you have to login or not but your
username is always PI and your password
is raspberry so that's all you need that
if you log in you can type in STAAR TX
and that takes you to your desktop and
you can kind of play around if you want
but the next video will start the next
steps in the super computer so anyways
hopefully you guys enjoyed as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and subscriptions and until next
time